[Musique]
c'était le thème avec notre invité la
semaine dernière la fête de la science à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la communauté
d'agglomération participent à cet
événement national organisé par le
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
ça a commencé le 30 septembre avec avec
différentes animations à saint quentin
ont fait le point avec mélanie pocket
j'avais dire ça commence et que mélanie
poker mais n'ont pas encore faudrait
peut-être non non en fait camion va
s'intéresser une animation en
particulier une exposition manip autour
de la lumière et des illusions d'optique
déjà kenya vous avez fait une question
tout à l'heure je vous imposer un bon
tour est ce que vous savez ce qu'est une
illusion d'optique
je veux dire joker non je dirais que
c'est quelque chose que notre oeil
peuvent voir mais qui n'est pas tout à
fait vrai bon allez on a vérifié je
préfère ne rien dire non plus antoine
vignal chargée d'action culturelle de
l'atelier des sciences nous donne sa
définition
c'est quelque chose qui nous semblent
réels mais ne l'est pas à une illusion
d'optique contrairement à ce qu'on pense
pas une illusion créée par l'oeil c'est
une illusion qu'on voit mais qui crée
par le cerveau notre cerveau lui va
créer en fait un une logique à tout ça
va créer l'image que l'on voit mais des
fois justement le cerveau se tromper
créer une logique là où il n'y en a pas
l'exposition est actuellement à la
médiathèque aimé-césaire de la verrière
mais elle est inhérente
alors elle reste à la verrière jusqu'au
15 octobre elle prendra ensuite la
direction de trappes elle passera à
elancourt pour prendre fin en décembre à
guyancourt
alors toutes les dates sont précisées
sur le site internet de 15 qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran
ça ce sont les informations pratiques
pour l'exposition plus précisément elle
s'intéresse à la lumière sous toutes ses
formes
écoutez on va vraiment abordé le thème
de la lumière mais sous à toutes ces
propriétés
on va passer la lumière dans la nature
la lumière le principe de des fractions
de diffusion de la lumière de
déformation la lumière de décomposition
de la lumière
vraiment on va apporter toutes les
propriétés physiques de la lumière aussi
en passant par le côté artistique et
l'exposition est composée de panneaux
mais packer pas que parce qu'à chaque
panneau qu'émilie à une manipulation qui
est proposé pour comprendre ce qui est
expliqué il y en a des simples à
réaliser des cinq six ans
certaines sont un peu plus con un peu
plus complexe parce qu'elle s'adresse à
un public plutôt lycéens
alors qu'amy je voudrais aussi terminé
sur un autre et vernant événement
toujours la fête de la science
l'ouverture officielle c'est alice
terminé de magny les hameaux que ça se
passe avec l'astro club de magnitude 78
des séances de planétarium vous
attendent dès l'âge de 5 ans merci
mélanie pour ce petit point scientifique
sur les illusions d'optique et on
termine cette émission par un dernier
rendez vous à noter